the nominees for Best Original Score who  made that kind of difference for movies  this year are progress of God George  Diller who for the color purple  Quincy Jones Jeremy Lovett rod  temperature crisis oh Semenya I print I  worked all day and an Andre Crouch Chris  Boardman Borg a calendar le Joe  Rosenbaum and Fred Steiner Jack Hayes  Jerry Hey and Randy Kerber for Africa  John Barry  for Silverado Bruce Bratton for witness  Maurice Jarre  and the winner is John Barry four out of  Africa  first and foremost I'd like to thank  Sydney [ __ ] the excellence of his  direction and the eloquence this  production I'd like to thank Dan Wallen  a music scoring mixer for just a  wonderful job and all the very fine  musicians each and every one of them who  perform the score for us  my wife Laurie members of the Academy I  thank you very much